hola la visita del presidente de donald
trump hoy a la corte suprema para
mostrar respetos al centro de la
magistrada quieren seguro generó
polémica y rechazo al interior de los
demócratas en el congreso
esta visita se dio mientras miles de
personas continúan llegando a la corte
suprema- a mostrar también sus respetos
y honrar la memoria de la magistrada que
luchó por las libertades civiles y la
igualdad de género pero las críticas de
los demócratas no se hicieron esperar ya
que el presidente no esperará hasta sus
honras fúnebres la próxima semana en el
cementerio nacional de arlington para
hacer el anuncio de su nominado para el
reemplazo de la magistrada que será este
próximo sábado y es que washington está
en medio de una batalla política debido
a si el presidente debe acelerar o no
este proceso cuando falta menos de un
mes y medio para las elecciones
presidenciales en el país mientras tanto
se espera que el féretro sea llevado el
día de mañana al capital